this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming platform built by
all your favorite youtubers when you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
[Music]
imagine for a moment a society in which
every human is afforded the basics of
life
a reasonable income a place to live
there's plenty of food and other
necessities for everyone
competition over scarce materials is no
longer necessary
this stage of progress is called post
scarcity if you've ever seen star trek
you're already familiar with the concept
of a highly advanced post-scarcity
society
jobs are optional and based on personal
preference and inclination
yielding many more people working in
creative fields and the arts than we see
in our modern reality
the federation doesn't use money despite
the existence of banks and credits which
is a little confusing but maybe a
trekkie can explain it in the comments
every once in a while there's a shortage
but as a general rule there's enough of
everything to go around
the actual economic structure of the
federation is unclear
there have been suggestions that it's a
form of techno-communist or highly
advanced socialist system
but it's never explicitly spelled out
what we do know is that the star trek
society has found a way to decouple
human value from work
and provide all their citizens the
necessities of life this is an advanced
form of what's called universal basic
income it's a fascinating idea and with
more and more jobs being performed more
quickly and cheaply by machines
it just might become a necessity in the
coming decades in this episode we're
going to look at some examples of ubi
trials in the real world and discuss
whether universal basic income might be
the future
when talking about seemingly crazy
economic plans like ubi
a lot of people's first reaction is one
of disbelief wait just give everyone
money that's crazy
or but humans need to work what else
will we do
these are both very understandable
objections at face value
but let's explore a bit further why do
we think giving people enough money to
survive
is crazy if we as a society have the
resources to provide a secure financial
floor
essentially eliminating poverty and the
societal problems that come with it
why wouldn't we do it i'm sure the
knee-jerk response would be because it's
expensive and that's a fair assessment
but we do a lot of expensive things
endless wars are expensive
health care is expensive infrastructure
is expensive but we
pay for all these things without batting
an eye but we'll get to the cost of ubi
later
in response to the claim that humans
need to work that work is supposedly our
natural state
sure meaningful use of our time may be
important but somehow i don't think
working on a production line making 30
different kinds of poop emoji pool
floats counts as meaningful work
the idea that our natural state is to
work for a wage is a perversion of the
understanding of existence
obviously we're not meant to just sit
around and do nothing but work doesn't
just mean standing at a cash register
all day
work in the fulfilling a human needs
sense can be anything from writing music
to rock climbing to creating art to
raising children to any number of other
things that don't earn you money in our
current system
today if we see someone who's not
employed whether they're creating
beautiful paintings in their mom's
basement or performing with their band
on a street corner
we consider them lazy and somehow worth
less than someone who sells hours of
their life for a wage
this is a problem if we can decouple
human value from wage labor
we'll have a much richer understanding
of what it means to be human
is working a meaningless job producing
cheap junk really any better than not
working
i don't think so and it's certainly not
more worthwhile than pursuing a passion
even if that passion doesn't pay some
people just want to work a simple job
that's fine but that needs to be
understood as a personal desire
not as a supposedly natural state
alright are we all on the same page
meaningful work is not the same thing as
having a day job now that we understand
why having a traditional job is not
critical to human flourishing
it seems a lot more reasonable to want
to provide everyone a basic income right
then we add in the possibility of
massive layoffs caused by increased
automation and a cool idea becomes an
imperative
what happens if self-driving trucks
eliminate all the trucking jobs
that's seven and a half million people
out of work or roughly six percent of
the entire u.s workforce
and trucking jobs aren't the only ones
at risk agriculture
fast food retail even things like
insurance underwriting they're all ripe
for a robot revolution
as alarming as this may seem we can take
a couple of different perspectives on
the change
on the one hand the cynic in me believes
that runaway capitalism will encourage
automation at the expense of human
workers
replacing them with cheap to run
machines that further enrich the already
obscenely wealthy
leaving millions to starve on the other
hand there is the possibility that a
universal basic income could be
implemented in tandem with this dramatic
shift in the labor landscape
freeing workers from their traditional
jobs allowing robots to do the menial
work and providing a base level of
security that would allow humans to
pursue their desires
whether that's improving themselves
taking a sabbatical or learning a craft
so we can choose to do nothing and end
up with a techno dystopia or begin to
seriously consider seemingly radical
ideas like ubi
but how radical is it really believe it
or not the notion of providing a basic
standard of living to a population has
been around since at least the 16th
century
since that time ubi has earned the
support of people from all across the
political spectrum
from rabid free-market enthusiasts like
milton friedman to proto-socialist
revolutionaries like thomas payne to
martin luther king to
most recently democratic presidential
hopeful andrew yang
it's not often that an idea gets the
support of such a philosophically
diverse bunch of people
of course opponents of ubi also come
from across the political landscape
let's have a look at some of the
arguments leveled against universal
basic income
first and foremost is the claim that
giving people quote free money will make
them lazy and disincentivize work
this is the same accusation that's used
when discussing welfare of any sort
and based on some preliminary data there
seems to be more of a correlation with
disincentivization with welfare of the
sort we see in america
versus less means-tested options like no
strings attached to ubi
of course we'll definitely want a larger
sample size before we make any huge
investments and replace the welfare
state with ubi
but there is some evidence to indicate
that when a person is guaranteed a
certain amount of money without the
stipulation of needing to seek work to
replace that money
they're actually more likely to find a
job you're probably thinking
wait that doesn't make any sense think
about it like this
many current welfare systems require
recipients to actively seek employment
but the money you get from welfare will
be reduced or removed entirely when you
find a job
and in many cases you'll be worse off
than you were before you found that job
this makes it far less appealing to look
for work if on the other hand you're
guaranteed the money regardless of what
job you get
you'd be much more likely to look for
work because you'd be making money from
that job
plus the ubi payments even a part-time
job would be an
option since as opposed to welfare
you'll keep receiving the ubi payments
at the very least the data does not
support the claim that ubi will lead to
lower employment
take alaska for example the alaska
permanent fund has provided each alaska
resident an annual check simply for
existing
this money comes from revenue derived
from the oil industry and is usually
around one to two thousand dollars
economists determined that these
payments have had no effect on
employment
but have effectively reduced extreme
poverty a recently concluded study in
finland reported similar results
recipients were no more or less likely
to seek work but reported improved
happiness and reduced levels of stress
one of the largest ubi programs
currently running and the only one
implemented at a national scale is in
iran
back in 2011 iran rolled out a new
program that distributed fairly large
monthly payments to families in order to
replace the phased-out subsidies for
electricity
fuel heating water and bread these
payments originally averaged roughly 29
of each family's income a significant
amount and have been scaled back in
recent years
but again economists found that the
monthly payments did not affect
employment numbers
we've seen similar results around the
world from kenya to india to namibia
and in each location the ubi payments
did not affect employment
but did increase mental and physical
well-being reduce poverty-related crime
and
increase school attendance the other
main argument against universal basic
income
is that it would be too expensive and
difficult to implement this is a serious
concern
estimates for establishing ubi in the
united states vary
but they're generally in the trillions
of dollars that's a lot of money
some opponents of ubi will say that
money is wasted or it's simply not
feasible
others including many of my fellow
socialists will say that ubi won't fix
the inherent problems of the capitalist
system
and that it would sap resources from
other pressing needs like implementing
universal healthcare
whereas the concern that ubi would
disincentivize work can be pretty well
dismissed at this point the cost and
efficacy concerns deserve some real
attention
there are ways we could reduce the
complexity of implementing ubi
like skipping the means testing entirely
and just giving every single adult a
flat payment
then taxing the very wealthy at a higher
rate to recoup that money
but we can't ignore the giant
multi-trillion dollar price tag
really it comes down to evaluating our
priorities are robots suddenly going to
take all the jobs
no it will be a gradual process and
really it's not even a sure thing
we have other more pressing concerns
like mitigating climate fallout and
implementing a humane healthcare system
that covers everyone and doesn't
bankrupt you for using it
and this is where everything falls apart
there are so many things we need to
spend money to fix
and no one will ever agree completely on
the right order in which to fix them
ubi is one of the more fascinating
proposals simply because it's so
polarizing and there's not a clear
ideological divide
maybe that's a good sign maybe not
whatever the future holds for ubi
i think it's an ideal we can all aspire
to a society where human value is not
derived from selling hours of your life
for a wage
where people can pursue their passions
and produce beautiful things to share
with the world
where everyone can afford the
necessities of life and poverty has
become a thing of the past
we'll debate the means of achieving this
goal for years to come
but at least it's a goal we can all
share
if you've seen my last few videos you'll
have noticed that youtube has been
demonetizing a lot of them
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula a
streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization since nebula is all about
creating thoughtful content we've
partnered with curiositystream
an established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content and the financial
security of those who produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game you can find tons of great
episodes like their dream the future
series
which offers hours of content you'll
love if you enjoyed this week's video
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiosity stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100 free
for a limited time curiosity stream is
offering 26 off their annual plan
that's less than 15 bucks a year for
both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time watching
fascinating documentaries on curiosity
stream
or check out nebula's original content
like real engineering's logistics of
world war ii series
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad-free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes if you hated it go ahead and
drop a thumbs down
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you